ok,
peut-être que tu pensais à te présenter
et que chaque sœur s'en prenne à moi pour
ta nouvelle année, tu
serais peut-être surpris que tu aies juste besoin de
quelque chose qui te distingue
[Musique]
mascotte de la maison Je vais me présenter à la
présidence
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes tellement pressés  nous
sommes vraiment excités par Alpha
et tu te
débarrasses du paresseux
désolé mais c'est toi ou moi
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont en train de disparaître c'est
un paresseux que tu ne peux pas planifier que nous
ne savons même pas à propos de ces choses,
est-ce qu'elle a eu l'air lente avec toi
as-tu vu le regard dans ses yeux, elle
ressemble à un mignon éléphant Chuck
étranger
[Musique]